What do we do with our ego is helped us
climb the dominance hierarchy is secure
a mate.
Why then should we keep looking for a
mate and how to curtail that instinct?
Well,
I think part of the way that you curtail
that inks in state is that you have,
you have this sort of life that
you would have with a mate.
The question is what's the
purpose of pair bonding?
And one of the fundamental purposes of
pair bonding while there's a couple one,
is that it solves the sexual access
problem so that you don't have to continue
to obsess about who you're
going to be within and,
and,
and where and how.
And so you can get on with
other elements of your life.
But I mean with,
with your mate,
you have to decide,
well,
what does it mean that
you're now together?
You know,
you're there,
there's companionship obviously,
and friendship and their shared interests.
You have to decide what they are.
And I would say that you should continue
dating your partner at least once a
week or perhaps twice a week because
otherwise the romance goes out of your
life.
But then also you have to decide
about children and eventually about
grandchildren because you know you're
going to get old and you're going to get
older and more mature and children are
a huge part of life and they get a bad
rap,
which is really unfortunate
because you know,
maybe I'm,
I'm different in this regard.
Perhaps I am to some degree,
but I never regretted having kids for
even one second because there are so mean.
All of a sudden you have an intimate
relationship with new people that is as
close as any relationship
that you've ever had.
You have the opportunity to make that
relationship as pristine as you possibly
can.
I mean,
there can be a lot of
catastrophe involved in it,
but it's a great opportunity and there's
just nothing wrong with having some
additional people that love you,
you know?
And so what you do is you turn your
attention to the issues of maturity and
you're tuning your attention away
from the issues of being a juvenile.
And you do that partly by knowing
that it's actually better to do.
So.
You know,
there's nothing more absurd than
the 40 year old 20 year old.
It gets ugly and there's something like,
there's something like
spoiled milk about it.
It goes off and you have to gracefully
accept the challenges of each stage of
life and things work a lot
better when you do that much,
much better.
And you also have to,
I would say,
work on and perfect your sex life with
your partner and express what you need
and want and teach each other what's
necessary to keep things exciting and,
and,
and new.
It's not an easy thing to do,
but it's very much worthwhile because
then you can combine sexual excitement
with intimacy and there's no
better combination than that.
So I'd love that can all be a
nested up inside love and inside,
uh,
you know,
a destiny that's intertwined together
and that's the best you've got man.
That that's,
that's,
that's what life has to offer.
And so,
um,
that's what you do is you accept the
responsibility of the next stage of life
and you don't mourn the past.
I suppose that also means
that when you're young,
you do what young people do and so
that you don't want to do it again.